aquí tenemos tres estructuras del mismo
kart vocación un kart vocación tiene un
carbono que está cargado positivamente
en química a eso se le conoce como un
catión entonces si combinamos las
palabras carbono y catión obtenemos
carbó catión primero veamos la
estructura de enmedio este carbono tiene
una carga positiva porque normalmente el
carbono tiene cuatro enlaces pero aquí
sólo tiene tres miren
tenemos 1 2 y 3 entonces como sólo tiene
3 enlaces tenemos una carga formal
positiva y los carbó cationes son muy
reactivos porque al carbono le gusta
tener sus 4 enlaces pero ahora
analicemos el carb ocasión del lado
izquierdo el carbono de color rosa tiene
la carga formal positiva y como no
estamos dibujando todos los átomos en
esta estructura a veces los estudiantes
olvidan que este carbono rosa tiene una
carga formal positiva y eso significa
que hay un hidrógeno unido
el no olviden eso cuando se encuentren
con este tipo de estructuras y
finalmente veamos el carbó catión de la
derecha el carbono rosa es este carbón
ahí es en donde se encuentra la carga
formal positiva y como el carbono rosa
sólo tiene tres enlaces este carbono
tiene una hibridación sp2 y por los
vídeos anteriores sabemos que un carbono
con hibridación sp2 tiene un orbital p
sin híbrida
este es el orbital p sin híbrida y la
geometría alrededor de ese carbono sp2
es plana trataré de dibujar el plan así
podemos indicar que los átomos unidos
directamente a ese carbono se encuentran
en un mismo plano alrededor del carbono
ok ahora veamos un modelo del mismo
carbó catión este es nuestro carbono con
hibridación sp2 y este es nuestro
orbital de vacío del lado izquierdo
tenemos un grupo metilo unido
directamente al carbono cargado
positivamente
y del lado derecho tenemos otro grupo
metil entonces como tenemos dos grupos
metilo unidos a ese carbono cargado
positivamente a esto se le conoce como
carbó catión secundario porque tenemos
dos grupos al kilo unidos directamente
al carbono con la carga positiva y estos
grupos al kilo pueden ayudar a
estabilizar el carbó catión porque miren
un poco de densidad electrónica en este
enlace se puede donar al orbital p vacío
los opuestos se atraen
entonces donar un poco de densidad
electrónica ayuda a estabilizar el carbó
catión por lo tanto los grupos al kilo
ayudan a estabilizar carbó cationes y
bueno el grupo al kilo del lado derecho
hace lo mismo un poco de densidad
electrónica ayuda a estabilizar el carbó
catión pero observen que en la parte de
atrás tenemos un hidrógeno y la densidad
electrónica
en este enlace no puede ser donada al
orbital p así que los grupos al kilo nos
ayudan a estar
al oscar vocaciones pero los hidrógenos
no tiene sentido que entre más grupos al
kilo tengamos más estable es el carbó
catión ya vimos que los grupos al kilo
ayudan a estabilizar a un kart vocación
al donar densidad electrónica a un
orbital p vacío y a este efecto se le
conoce como hiper conjugación entonces
conforme incrementamos el número de
grupos al kilo aumenta la estabilidad
del carbó catión analicemos el kart
vocación de la izquierda aquí sólo
tenemos un grupo al kilo unido
directamente a este carbono cargado
positivamente por lo tanto este es un
kart vocación primario después aquí
tenemos dos grupos al kilo unidos
directamente a este carbono cargado
positivamente por lo tanto es un kart
vocación secundaria como el que tenemos
en la fotografía y finalmente si tenemos
tres grupos al kilo unidos directamente
al carbono cargado positivamente ese es
un kart vocación
entonces entre más grupos alquilo
tengamos más estable es el carbó catión
por lo tanto un carbó catión terciario
es más estable que un kart vocación
secundario y un kart vocación secundario
es mucho más estable que un kart
vocación primario de hecho este kart
vocación es tan inestable que no existe
entonces vamos a enfocarnos en los carbó
cationes secundarios y terciarios ahora
que entendimos la estabilidad del kart
vocación veamos una introducción a los
arreglos de carbó cationes un posible
arreglo es algo llamado cambio de
hidruro pero primero veamos qué es un
ión hidruro sabemos que el hidrógeno
tiene un electrón de valencia y si le
quitamos ese electrón nos queda h más
que ya sabemos que es un protón pero si
agregamos un electrón al átomo de
hidrógeno neutro ahora tenemos dos
electrones de valencia lo que le da una
carga formal negativa
es el ión hidruro entonces al hidrógeno
con dos electrones y una carga formal
negativa se le conoce como hidruro así
que podemos hacer un cambio de hidruro
para formar un kart vocación más estable
entonces analicemos este carbó catión
sabemos que este carbono tiene una carga
formal positiva aquí tenemos un grupo
alquiló y aquí tenemos otro por lo tanto
este es un kart vocación secundaria y
podemos hacer un cambio de hidruro pero
antes de enseñarles cómo veamos el
siguiente vídeo para que lo vean mejor
con un modelo molecular
este es el kart vocación secundario y
podemos ver que la geometría alrededor
de ese carbono con hibridación sp2 es
plana y también podemos ver el orbital
de vacío con estas paletas y tenemos dos
grupos al kilo unidos directamente a
este carbón a la derecha tenemos un
grupo metilo y a la izquierda tenemos
este grupo al kilo grande y atrás
tenemos un hidrógeno
ahora observen que donamos un poco de
densidad electrónica de este enlace al
orbital de vacío y eso ayuda a
estabilizar el carbó catión pero vamos a
quitar las paletas para que podamos ver
el cambio de hidruro recuerden un
hidruro es un hidrógeno con dos
electrones
entonces tomaré este hidrógeno junto con
los dos electrones del enlace y vamos a
cambiarlos de este carbono al carbono de
la derecha ese es un cambio de hidruro y
miren del lado izquierdo le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono por lo que ahora
este carbono está cargado positivamente
y debe de ser plano pero aquí no lo
vemos porque en este modelo molecular he
usado un carbono tetraedro pero ahorita
les mostraré un modelo nuevo para que
vean que es plano y bueno del lado
derecho esto debe de ser tetraedro este
carbono paso de tener una hibridación
sp2 a una sp3 déjenme mostrarles el
nuevo modelo molecular para que lo vean
mejor
este es el carbono que ahora tiene una
hibridación sp2 podemos ver que tiene
una geometría plana a su alrededor y
este es un kart vocación terciario aquí
tenemos un grupo metilo un grupo metilo
aquí y un grupo metilo acá entonces un
carbó catión terciario es más estable
que uno secundario y también podemos ver
que este carbono ahora tiene una
hibridación sp3 por lo que la geometría
alrededor de ese carbono es detraer y
acá pasamos de una geometría plana a una
te trae drica dibujemos el cambio de
hidruro que vimos en el vídeo sabemos
que en este carbono tenemos un hidrógeno
y podemos mover el hidrógeno junto con
estos dos electrones a este carbono de
la derecha para formar un kart vocación
más estable entonces dibujemos ese nuevo
kart vocación ok y aquí tenemos el
hidrógeno que he puesto de color rojo y
le quitamos un enlace a este carbono de
la izquierda que corresponde a este
carbón ese es el carbó catión terciario
que vimos en el vídeo entonces tenemos
una carga formal positiva en este
carbono y observen que al inicio ya
teníamos un hidrógeno en este carbono
vamos a dibujarlo ok y como el objetivo
es formar un kart vocación más estable
con un regla aquí pasamos de un kart
vocación secundario a un kart vocación
terciario que ya sabemos que es más
estable
finalmente veamos otro tipo de regla a
este cambio se le conoce como cambio de
metilo y aquí tenemos un kart vocación
secundario porque el carbono con la
carga formal positiva está unido
directamente a un grupo metilo y a este
grupo alquilo entonces para un cambio de
metilo podemos tomar este grupo metilo y
podemos moverlo del carbono de la
izquierda a este carbono de la derecha
usemos algunos colores vamos a
identificar al carbono de la izquierda
de color rojo y al carbono de la derecha
de color azul
el grupo metilo se cambia del carbono
rojo al azul dibujemos el resultado de
ese cambio de metil ahora tenemos un
kart vocación que se ve así entonces el
carbono rojo pierde un enlace este
carbono rojo tiene una hibridación sp3
este trae trico pero cuando pierde un
enlace
este es el carbono rojo y ahora tiene
una hibridación el cp2 tiene una
geometría plana y una carga formal
positiva mientras que el carbono azul
que tenía una hibridación sp2 y era
plano ganó un grupo metilo verdad este
es el grupo metilo y este es el carbono
de color azul que pasa de tener una
hibridación sp2 a una hibridación sp3 y
recuerden que desde el principio ya
teníamos un hidrógeno en este carbono
azul vamos a dibujarlo en el carbó
catión así que este es un carbó catión
terciario y sabemos que es más estable
que uno secundario entonces con un
de metilo obtenemos un kart vocación más
estable